Hollywood history is littered with rag
to riches stories though few of them are
quite as literal as Chris Pratt's now
the face of Marvel's guardians of the
galaxy movies price has become an
incredibly long way since he dropped out
of college at 17 after just a single
semester taking the road less traveled
on his way to Tinseltown I have a plan
you've got a plan yes after cutting his
teeth playing sidekicks in the funny man
the character actor was immediately
promoted to the a-list when he won the
role of Marvel Studios Peter quill aka
star-lord turned back the clock a few
years however and there were definitely
no red carpets or caviar so how did it
happen let's find out how Chris Pratt
went from homeless becomes a Hollywood
hotshot after dropping out of school
Pratt's had to find ways to make ends
meet and he turned out to be a natural
at door-to-door sales he worked as a
coupon salesman for two years learning
skills that he claimed to served him
well when he finally made his three move
into acting his next gig was less
white-collar or actually more no color
in need of a bit of extra cash price
decided to turn himself into what was
described as a very very low rent Magic
Mike just like slowly awkwardly dance
and then take go down to my shorts and
they'll be like no with next to nothing
to lose and his twenties looming Pratt
accepted an invitation from an old
friend who claimed to be living the
dream in Hawaii and wanted his buddy to
join him the two younger men lived out
of Havana which Pratt admits had his ups
and downs on one hand he was very free
but on the other hand you have no
bathroom and the van had a bit of
problem with fleas and rats and of
course there was also the danger of him
turning into this I am 35 years old I am
divorced and I live in a van down by the
river one of the part-time positions
Pratt picked up in the islands of Aloha
was waiting tables at a bubblegum
seafood restaurant
it was while on shift at the diner that
Pratt had a chance encounter with
commando actress and shrimp fan Rae dawn
Chong who was looking for actors for her
comedy horror short cursed part 3 after
being impressed by his enthusiasm Chong
flew Pratt to LA to give him a shot and
ended up providing him that the platform
had been waiting for
Pratt's next acting gig came when he
landed the role of Kenan in the
dream team a 2003 GNX spy flick about a
secret group of black ops snowboarders
that movie sounds ridiculous but in the
grand scheme it was just another rung in
the ladder de prata to climb on his way
to becoming star-lord
despite finally seeing himself as a
professional actor things didn't exactly
fall into place right away in terms of
auditions Pratt made some cash during
commercials but eventually his
persistence paid off landing him the
path of high school jerk right upwards
on The WB drama Everwood
apparently Pratt it didn't even really
prepare for this audition and the land
of the part by just naturally being the
type of character that the directors
were looking for funny how things work
out
Pratt's wasted no time getting
comfortable on the set of Everwood where
he would end up portraying Brides in 89
episodes between 2002 and 2006 when
Everwood wrapped up in no.6 Pratt
secured a recurring role on long-running
Fox favorite the Yosi appearing in nine
episodes as left-wing activist and
occasional naked guitarist Jay Cooke
after these roles Pratt finally landed
what most people consider his big break
with the role of Andy Dwyer on Parks and
Recreation my full name is andrew i
think so
no wait yes paws move on the critically
acclaimed the mockumentary opened a new
avenues for Pratt who atributes the
show's continued success to lead actress
Amy Poehler amazingly Pratt's character
Andy Dwyer was only supposed to appear
in five or six episodes but when he
turned out to be a fun favorite he
became part of the main cast for the
show's entire run let's say I taped your
symptoms into the thing up here it says
you could have network connectivity
problems the success of Parks and
Recreation and the codes following that
started to build around perhaps
character made movie studios pay
attention in the next few years he had
roles in 2011 Best Picture nominee
Moneyball Judd Apatow 2012 comedy The
Five Year Engagement the war drama zero
dark thirty and 2013's Best Picture
nominated film her with all these strong
big screen performances sucking up it
seemed like Russ was poised to shake the
funny friend stereotype and trade it up
for something much bigger that much
bigger thing would of course be 2014
massive hair - guardians of the galaxy -
sir James Gunn admitted that when
Pratt's name first appeared on his desk
he scoffed at the idea of him leading
the line of star-lord John even said
that there was no way that quote the
chubby guy from Parks and Rec was going
to star in his movie at this point Pratt
had already been turned down for the
parts of James Kirk in the Star Trek
reboot and a Jake Sully in Avatar
because he didn't have the it factor and
he himself was worried that he was too
far to play a superhero but in the end
both he and Gunn were wrong as soon as a
director saw Pratt reading for the path
he was sold and apparently knew he had
found a star Lord just 20 seconds into
the audition just like that the part was
his though that's pretty much all Pratt
knew for a good while the actor has
explained that his contract with Marvel
Studios was brief at that stage to the
point where he wasn't even allowed to
see the screenplay the radio silence
lasted so long that Pratt still had no
clue what was happening when he met up
with Gunn to discuss the movie
thankfully that meeting went very well
and was enough to compact nerves after
that the actor was ready to become
starring Lord who star Lord and
legendary outlaw at that point there was
only one thing left to do Pratt tipped
the scale at 300 pounds when he went in
to audition for guardians of the galaxy
and it was only after winning the role
that he made a vow to shed some of it 60
pounds to be exact the actor lost the
weight over a period of six months even
a workout that included running swimming
kickboxing and even a full triathlon for
some reason however dancing wasn't part
of the fitness regimen dance-off row me
versus you it's on
by the time the guardians of the galaxy
she began prowl looked like a genuine
superhero with a six-pack and all this
rips bud coupled with its undeniably
lovable personality has helped perhaps
Korea take off scoring him lead roles in
big movies like Jurassic world
passengers and the Magnificent Seven
as Pratt's movie Korea continues to heat
up one thing is becoming more and more
clear the guy is a seriously ripped
seriously funny actor who isn't going
anywhere except a right to the top of
Hollywood's a-list of course no matter
how famous he gets Pratt will always be
this guy yep
my pants on camera check thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your loved team
[Music]
[Applause]